i won't miss the corset seven years is a
big chunk of one's life i won't miss
having the rubber glow to my face every
day
after traveling light years through
space and 171 episodes
the crew of star trek voyager is coming
home and we're on the set for the top
secret final episode
we've had a couple of days that were a
little bittersweet
a couple scenes specifically but for the
most part it's still you know very
lighthearted and very fun and very goofy
and
sort of uncontrolled chaos what does it
say about that would be jerry ryan
crooning in the background right there
because we're in the countdown
and i think as it becomes more real to
all of us it's gonna start getting a
little sad
i think they did a wonderful job tying
it up
very unexpected very unpredictable
welcome aboard
it's good to be back the poignancy is is
also
a surprise uh and catches one unaware
i think the audience will tune in
thinking uh i've got this pretty well
figured out you know it will be a
a game for most of them they'll have
calculated the odds against this and
what's going to happen but so-and-so
and i think they will find themselves
unsettled by what in fact the writers
have come up with which is
profoundly clever and very moving i've
been with these people for four years
they've been together for seven
and you really do become like a family
because you see them more than you see
your family
and i don't think i've ever laughed as
hard in my life as i have working on
this show
that's the single most difficult thing
about my character is having to keep a
straight face playing with these guys
because it really is a fun warm
goofy insane group of people you know
what i shouldn't be listening to details
about the future
oh the almighty temporal prime directive
take my advice
it's less of a headache if you just
ignore it seven years is a very long
time
an experience of so many colors and
components and layers
i certainly will miss the people then
i'll miss this character she's been
a joy to play a real gift as an actor
our thoughts are one and now i can look
back
and really applaud the writers and
producers for the way that they've
developed seven and
the remarkable restraint that they've
shown in developing her character
i think it's very very important to
stand back after something like this and
reassess one's life
there are great challenges ahead i hope
i hope they're noble
challenges and i hope that their
challenges of love but
there is absolutely no more loyal
passionate dare i say rabid group
of fans than star trek fans they really
i think more so than any other fans
embrace you as someone that they really
welcome
wholeheartedly into their home every
week
[Music]
said of course for home